[Music]
did you see the new post mates
commercial for pride
no
okay this is you know what post mates is
right it's kind of like uber
you know they pick [ __ ] up for you and
stuff like that you all know what
postmates is right mm-hmm okay
what are you eating this pride
[Music]
well if you're a top it seems like you
can eat whatever you want
it's for postmates
but
why is everything but sex
why can't you just bring me my food no
i'm not even hungry thanks a lot poster
now you're horny i get it
but if you're a bottom you're expected
to starve
i don't know the exact same
community but what is are they saying
euphemism
are they saying bottoms
in the gay community
aren't respected is that what they're
saying
well they're saying they don't get
theirs food so it's food or euphemism
for coming since you're the bottom what
does this have to do with postmates
tops can eat whatever they want are you
craving tacos you filthy [ __ ] bottom i
don't think so last thing i want is [ __ ]
all over my dick [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're like
yeah i just wanted to see if you'd run
to um wawa for me
the jokes aside i think that is
generally what they are because it says
the bottom friendly menu i think they
are genuinely saying that like
guys who get [ __ ] in the ass all the
time need to have like a specific diet
oh my god are you serious you're right
introducing introducing the bottom
friendly menu
yep so in the gay community i guess you
have to eat a certain way if you're a
bottom because you get [ __ ] in the
butt right
i would assume and what they're saying
is is that postmates has
a bottom friendly menu
so you could buy it doesn't have to be
bottom like like gay like you know women
should pay attention too
they get [ __ ] and he has to that's
true
god will i mean on your birthday
probably
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical who
doctor who
dr [ __ ] no no no i hear the dog was
actually
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical to bring really you
immensely
with my new diet you'll never go poo poo
on your lover's penis ever again
see i play espanol
friendly foods backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel cute
so avoid things like whole grains sweet
bran cauliflower potatoes legumes
hold up are you just fully diving into
those b this is real
this really is a commercial of what not
to eat can i ask something so you don't
[ __ ] on people's dicks
can i ask something here just
what if you really like beans i know i'm
thinking the same thing what's happening
right now there's a fruit a literal
fruit by the way that i'm not being
visually there's a literal fruit bathing
in beans but i'm asking more
existentially what's happening
existentially a bunch of fruits have
marsh i don't think you get it how are
you supposed to get [ __ ] in the ass
when all you eat is bust lentils that's
a good point marsh
hey that's a good point so now you can't
eat your butt's lentils and get [ __ ]
in the butt what a great world we live
in
you can't have
dude guys i'm so sorry to butt in like
this sure but
i i just looked up evan goldstein
he's a surgeon for what
he he his entire practice
is built around repairing blown out gay
[ __ ]
yes
he's a prolapsed [ __ ] doctor what i
swear to god i'll read it for you hold
on
dr evan goldstein is a nationally
renowned doctor
oh i knew i knew him he's from that ryan
murphy show nip taint
so he's a so he's a busy doctor
his practice caters to a wide range of
clientele however the majority of his
patients are lgbtq he's a [ __ ] dog he's
a [ __ ] doctor
that's what he is
i can't
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you have a do you have a pink sock
call evan goldberg the bustle dock
there you go we have a commercial for
him
that's what the billboards say do you
have a pink sock call evan goldberg the
bussy doc
888 prolips
i just put it in show links oh [ __ ]
christ
i'm sorry you could understand why no
please no listen i would have been mad
at you if you didn't
by the way taper you're gonna be very
busy or enjoy a pet somebody has to make
now an evan goldberg
md
uh
yeah do you have a pink sock call the
busty doc we need that please
is your cornhole more like a cone corn
sock okay
all right
doctor is your [ __ ] functioning like
the head gasket of an old mercury grand
marquis
dr evan goldstein dr evan goldstein is a
nationally renowned anal surgeon
and the
imagine that was like that was that's
what you went into
he's a world renowned anal search
he's like well in my city there's
already enough there's
okay let me read this doctor what am i
supposed to do compete with 4 000
dentists in the upper west side or do
this
[ __ ] rid [ __ ] in the chat said
ganecologist
dr evan goldstein is a naturally
renowned anal surgeon
and the founder and ceo of bespoke
surgical the leading private practice
specializing in elite standard of sexual
health wellness and care in new york
city his practice care is giving a wide
range of clientele however the majority
of patients are lgbtq plus yeah they're
a wide range of clientele all right
that's why they're going to see the butt
doctor dr goldstein is also the
co-founder of future method so it sounds
like a [ __ ] rap group an innovation
it's your [ __ ] lost its elasticity
and its tensile tr strength give me a
call i'll help you today free
consultations
uh and you know what's gonna happen five
years from now did you get your [ __ ]
repaired by dr evan goldstein you're
entitled to a class-action lawsuit yeah
it turns out he's not a doctor
like this
[Music]
it turns out that he's not really a
doctor and his parents were just uh
seamstresses
he had had a bunch of bunch of cartoon
mice helping him repair somebody's
[ __ ] like cinderella my family ran a
garment factory and i just sort of
figured hey what if we applied the same
thing to [ __ ]
i'm the heir to the biggest rubber band
dynasty in the north america
hey royce yeah race hover over services
where services up at the top oh good
hold on guys let's read some services
here by the way i want to point out this
is because of a postmates commercial
services
anal restoration anal restoration hold
on wait there's
there's a subcategory you ready maybe
you know what honestly though maybe if
you need anal restoration you shouldn't
be treating your [ __ ] like like uh
old authentic wood flooring okay look at
this uh yeah they put a shack carpet
over his [ __ ] yeah they're making it
sound like your [ __ ] is a flooded
house
uh anal restoration let's read some of
the subcategories
uh anal restoration goes into anal
surgery [ __ ] up when you need full-on
you must reconstruction
anal reconstructive surgery yeah we're
gonna have to take out the old anus and
just put a new one in we're gonna need a
whole new home you can you know what you
can't restore anus you gotta go brand
new you need everything from a box anus
all the way down to anus mounts you're
gonna need everything
look i want i got to tell you your anus
is totaled all right it's totaled we're
gonna have to just
get into airbag deployed yeah look the
side impact airbags deployed in anus so
trust me trust me i'm a professional i
practice for years on real calamari you
have good hands oh god
it's so gross bro it's really gross dude
one of them is anal abscesses and
fistulas yes are there men getting
[ __ ] in the ass so hard they develop a
nose bridge in their [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh the answer yes anal fissures anal
incontinence anal pap smear anal skin
tags apv hpv anal warts pregnancy
hemorrhoids
prevention anal botox hold on what is
animals anal training is the next one
well i there's only one way to find out
my [ __ ] looks 22 again anal training
learn about anal stretching and training
from the experts at bespoke surgical
it's a wonder it's a wonder how to
stretch your anus to ever wonder how to
stretch your anus safely
or no you want to learn more about what
anal strain
a little bit more
do this by myself bespoke as a surgical
surgical
bespoke surgical has created a complete
guide to answer all your questions our
anal stretching guide
our anal stretching guide will teach you
how to stretch your [ __ ] safely
without oh my god it literally in a
medical page it says [ __ ]
well we gotta abuse plain language for
the layman with
with this professional medical guide
we're gonna teach you how to take that
[ __ ] deep in your [ __ ] [ __ ] bruh
jesus [ __ ] homo
what is that huh you like that [ __ ] boy
what is angel training and anal
stretching
just like working out any part of your
body sphincter muscles also need to be
trained for maximum flexibility this
anal training process also called anal
stretching or dilation often involves
the act of opening widening or
stretching the anus with tools called
anal dilators obviously it does
or anal expanders it is often done after
surgical procedures on the anus to
restore the area to its normal state or
as a method to prevent anal fissures
anal stretching can make passing school
or sexual activity more comfortable
um to both functionality along with
aesthetics desire to learn how to
stretch your sphincter muscle and anal
muscles keep reading if you're new to
anal intercourse consider checking out
the science of anal sex
check this science
that looks like a medieval torture
device there it is
that's a that's a torture device come on
let's go
let's do it
who's first
try to felt your [ __ ]
who's first
this is this is unbelievable
that looks like that looks like i
upgraded my grenade in halo
it looks like that cerebral bore from
phantasm that drills into your head and
drains all the blood from it i just want
you guys to take a moment and just just
really think about the scene before they
made this commercial
where they were looking on the internet
and they came across this website and
they just went
that's the guy this is the guy this is
the guy we need to make our
postmates commercial hey don't worry
about it i know i got a i know a really
good [ __ ] guy
i gotta go he's great dude and you know
what he's not gonna charge you up the
ass
that's a good angle i like that
well yeah there there's a commercial dr
evic gold state just cause we fix your
[ __ ] doesn't mean we're going to
charge you out of it
okay let's go let's make some
commercials for this guy for free it's
as they don't dissolve thank god oh my
god there's do's and don'ts okay hold on
let's see the dudes what are the dues
look at the don'ts no attendees sorry
okay on your dick sorry yeah hold on
yeah by the way bessie's the only reason
pessy's not gay is because he likes
chicken tenders too much
sorry
the only reason
sorry bro i'm not sitting on your dick
what's a good lie
two reasons i'm not two reasons i'm not
gay because i love chicken nuggets and
cause penises are too funny
this is bananas
not to you know name another food that
probably i think that's a dew i think
that's a dude
the problem with these foods is they
don't dissolve in water banana they
don't dissolve in water which could
cause a traffic jam in your digestive
system there's bananas there you go you
can eat bananas you can eat bananas
in the ass which way do you which way do
you eat them a mess of your evening
speaking of medicine
oh my god
it's a good idea
looks like
dairy
that's where evan goldstein comes in
the [ __ ] master
a little [ __ ] a little moth a little
matzo ball shows up [ __ ] with
dressing a little doctor outfit i could
fix this mouth he cracks his fingers
yeah
not handsome
you eat enough muzzle balls you're not
[ __ ] for two weeks
now look at them
if you're going to eat something
insoluble give your body about 24 hours
to process all of it
so you have to plan out your butt sex
huh is that how it works man i don't
know how any of this works you know
but i i don't i don't understand
why this is a postmates commercial you
don't understand how diet ties into butt
sex no no i'm trying to understand what
this has to do with a food delivery
service
soluble fibers and protein are the key
to having some good clean fun these all
digest easily and slowly while feeding
your gut i'm sorry but it's never clean
in the eyes of our lord and savior jesus
christ you will always be filthy
postmates
bacteria
which makes sushi a great bottom
friendly option
i love sushi you've just ruined sushi
for me now every time i eat sushi i'm
gonna think i could have somebody [ __ ]
me in the butt tonight way super excited
thanks postmates
thanks best i would just think this is
really good sushi
why is why is the eggplant wearing a
dominatrix outfit guys
because it's 20 22. it's nice for them
to have a black guy there we're all
doomed
i was gonna make a joke
thanks postmates now i can't eat sashimi
out of my lover's [ __ ] i hate you
thanks a lot
now every time we need sushi i'm gonna
get a boner and by the way now that i'm
not even sashimi out of my lover's
[ __ ] guess who that hurts guess who's
bottom line that hurts you you you
because i'm gonna get less delivered now
there's no right or wrong way to bottom
but if you're playing there is
absolutely a wrong way to bottle
depending on getting peachy this pride
the bottom friendly menu on postmates
has the kinds of foods that could keep
you feeling good are you organic all
right who here has postmates out of all
of us
are you the only one with post mates
no i don't have it it's not oh you
wanted to see the pride friendly menu i
wanted to see what the food was
hold on i'll
have a website
let's go to postmates yeah but i think
you have to like have an account and
find food around you
i believe
i i will check
anyway
uh that was fun and disgusting and
eye-opening and horrifying and
it was everything rest in peace america
it was nice knowing you guys